i'm janis dean i'm brett baer i'm martha
mccallum and this is the fox news
rundown
friday april 1st 2022 i'm dave anthony
we're now six weeks into russia's war on
ukraine heartbreaking to congresswoman
victoria sparts who was born there with
a grandmother among the many in dire
straits there we really don't have any
direct communications with her because
the area where she is it's been bombed
and really there is no access no phones
are working there these people with been
without water electricity for several
weeks now so it's going to get pretty
bad
elisa brady is it time to hit control
alt delete in american politics so
things can get done again just because
we've been doing something the same way
for the last couple of decades doesn't
mean we have to continue by doing it and
i'm james carafano and i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
for a 37th day
russia is attacking ukraine russia is
doing genocide on ukrainian territories
people of marijuana are now hostages
anastasia rodina's a member of
parliament mariopol's in ruins most of
the housing destroyed thousands of
people have been killed they are
literally dying because they don't not
not just because they are constantly
shelled but because they do not have
water they do not have food and today
the red cross is working with ukraine's
government trying to rescue more of the
over 100 000 civilians trapped in that
city hoping to bust them out of mariopol
though russia has made that difficult in
the past working with our nato allies
and our european partners and beyond
that
we uh we're responding we're
aiding the ukrainian people both
economically militarily but president
biden adds putin's war is imposing the
cost on america and our allies and
democracies around the world and the
president's trying to reduce near-record
gas prices here by releasing more oil
from the u.s strategic petroleum reserve
after banning russian oil imports
further squeezing russian leader
vladimir putin
he claims the west is waging an economic
war on russia
as russia claims it's pulling back
forces from some areas of ukraine we
need to judge russia on
their actions not on their words nato
leader yen stoltenberg and president
biden both say they are skeptical as
russia keeps shelling those same areas
it's all one long nightmare for
congresswoman victoria sparts being
ukrainian born i have a lot of people
from around the country reaching out and
sharing stories and sharing is what's
happening you know people from ukraine
reaching out she was actually born in
ukraine when it was the soviet union now
congresswoman sparks is an american a
republican from indiana the atrocity and
really these people living through hell
that happen in that country it's just
heartbreaking for me as a human being
yeah and you know and you know that land
you lived there for 22 years of your
life
where in ukraine is your family i know
you still have family there
right well actually it's in one of the
regions that's supposed to be
de-escalated on the recent talks from
turkey but in reality actually been
escalating this is one of the first
areas that was uh tried to be taken by
russia it's chernikov city of chernikov
chinese regions it's in the border with
russia and belarus and the city of
churnigo is heroic they've been standing
the ground for weeks now getting shelled
getting surrounded with no water no
electricity and i am i'm shocked they're
still fighting they were not able to
take that city and it's really getting
humanitarian catastrophe inside that
city but people are standing the ground
and fighting yeah and then russia was
supposed to be pulling back forces from
around there but they've still been
bombing it this week
oh no they actually escalated bombing
for the in the last two days it's
non-stop shelling now and you know they
were trying international organizations
try to bring some supplies in the city
they're refusing and i actually heard
some ukrainians try to do that some
member of their parliament husband was
trying to drive supplies humanitarian
supplies and he was killed
not just yesterday so i think it's
actually very bad situation over there
and a lot of old people and children is
still left in that city it's a large
city and it's you know it's getting
pretty bad so i think you know they're i
mean it's not surprising but they're
liars and they're lying right now that
they actually escalated in the key of
region insurgent region instead of
de-escalating the us has sent aid the us
has sent weapons
what more do you want the us to do to
try to stop vladimir putin you know we
actually it was very generous what
congress did allocate to help you know
but nothing is happening there on the
ground these organizations are not
really operationally in ukraine or
outside of ukraine which is really
surprising for me i understand that they
have challenges inside the country but
having challenges in poland and have it
over a month not to establish any
significant operations we have to ask
questions from usaid and all of these
people what are they doing because it's
becoming a huge humanitarian catastrophe
out there too and congress has an
oversight responsibility to our
taxpayers when we allocate this money to
help for these people to survive and
help europe to survive and really bring
some stability back to the world to
actually ask questions and we need to
ask these questions and i hope my
democrat colleagues will support me on
that but also with the defense of aid we
also kind of been dragging our feet
trying to play catch up and the only
thing russians understand and put and
understand is strengths
you know ukrainian people
they build a lot of resistance he didn't
expect that now he understands
that it's tougher for him but he is not
ready yet to really negotiate peace so
if we want him to get to the table he
needs to understand that it is serious
it's not temporary and it's going to put
his
you know existence of his power in his
country at stake and he will understand
that he need to start dealing with this
situation yeah they're supposed to be
more peace talks on friday what can you
even do in a negotiation with russia
what how can ukraine get russia to agree
to stop the fighting is there anything
on the
negotiating the table that can be done
well i think the only way they will come
to an agreement if they understand
that they're going to lose this war and
i think they are going to lose it in the
end but i don't think they think it's
still as imminent you know they talk
about all of this evil ukrainians and
all these things you know but actually
the populations of states they just
bombed and destroyed like haruki
churning of marijuana has a lot of
actually russian-born people i was
talking to my mother most of neighbors
that i knew from churny you know either
their spouses or their brothers this is
actually that live they actually russian
born not just russian speaking actually
were born in russia they have relatives
in russia
and right now their relatives may be
brainwashed but at some point they will
understand that they're killing their
brothers and
sisters and it's going to be a problem
for him too yeah yeah and well
the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky has said he's not going to give
up any land or anything in these peace
talks russia wants areas in the eastern
part of the country that it's already
taken right
well of course and they will try to do
as much as they can do and i and you
know they have to have in the agreement
and there are some things that
ukrainians are willing to agree and so i
think they need to do but i think a
territory of the ukraine is a sovereign
country and no country should be able to
come in europe in our age and say i want
a piece of territory this is actually
not just a challenge to ukraine a
challenge to the world order you know
that's how world war ii started in when
when germany decided to you know come
and check
you know republicans starting doing all
these different things so that is a
slippery slope to start dividing
european territories or any territories
really the international community has
to see what kind of security they could
be provided in assurances to keep peace
so that's not going to be another war
again
we mentioned congresswoman spartz has
family still in ukraine a few weeks ago
she got a scare my grandma turned in 95
today and we couldn't reach her then she
said right before that interview on fox
news channel my mom just called me a few
minutes ago and told me that
we reached her neighbor and the building
next to her was hit and that blew out
all the windows of her grandmother's
apartment so they moved into the
basement so at least for now they're
safe in the basement that was then how's
grandma doing now
i we really don't have communications
with her
directly because uh
you know they have no electricity and
so no phones are working and
already for a few weeks
so i've you know my mom just only has
communication from some people she knows
that uh you know check on her i think
she was alive at least in the recent
time they saw her but we really don't
have any direct communications with her
because the area where she is it's been
bombed and really there is no access no
phones are working there these people
with been without water electricity for
several weeks now so it's going to get
pretty bad
you know she talked to one of her
neighbors and uh she said that the woman
was standing for six hours to get bottle
of water when i was at the border you
know i actually you know i talked to
some woman that came from mariupol and
she said they were trying to get water
from the river but it's not a very good
water so you'll have a lot of disease
and other things happening you know and
i think that's what some of these cities
on the seas now experiences you know
lack of food and lack of water but
everyone who tries to escape they shoot
at people they're watching them how they
mine some of the fields around cities
doing watching how people get blown up
on these mines and if somebody tried to
escape just pretty much switch snipers
and shoot them so not allow people to
escape
so i mean they want people to die in the
cities but this is we're talking about
hundred thousands of people
under siege this is a lot of people and
somehow international community has to
put pressure on russian to start dealing
with that and allow some safe passages
to evacuate some children and old people
and people that
really in a terrible situation you
mentioned poland earlier a majority of
the more than four million ukrainians
who fled the country and are now
refugees are in poland you went there in
early march
you talked to people
what did you see
well i think it's it's unfortunate that
you know that
we don't have as much presence and help
of international organizations to help
poland i think polish people are amazing
what they're doing for ukrainians i mean
they're bringing people in their homes
they feeding people they treating people
they provide everything for them but
it's too big of a crisis for one country
to handle and i think poland needs to be
helped and especially by eu and other
countries to make sure that it doesn't
destabilize the whole country because
it's now running a risk not just for
ukrainians that they can be in the hands
of criminals and when i went you know
last weekend there it's two weeks later
i actually saw escalation of really
criminal activity and it's very obvious
when you go to the border you go to
train station and there are a lot of bad
people trying to look for easy victims
for human trafficking child trafficking
much more now you have people that you
know came from ukraine with no means
don't know anyone from war zones with
very stressed out so they can be easy
victims and you can see that criminal
activity including russian criminal
activity will be start really increasing
there to try to destabilize the country
so i think it's important to help poland
to deal with the situation effectively
because it's not just a problem for them
it's a problem for the whole europe well
we wish your family well we hope for the
best and uh we thank you very much
congresswoman victoria spartz republican
from indiana thank you so much thank you
thank you for having me
[Music]
this is james carafano with your fox
news commentary coming up
while president biden blames russia's
president and the pandemic for inflation
republicans keep pointing the finger at
him like texas senator and former
presidential hopeful ted cruz we're
seeing jimmy carter 2.0 hyperinflation
stagflation disasters abroad a weak
president but democrats are pointing
right back senate majority leader chuck
schumer defending the broader biden
agenda republicans seem to think it's
radical for the federal government to
dedicate resources to a clean energy
future and that's tame compared to the
non-stop lame game on social media in
the long run up to the midterm elections
and where it can feel like campaign
season never really ends i always find
people should be more critical of your
own team because you have you can do
something about it will hurt is a former
three-term republican congressman from
texas he's also been a cia officer a
cyber security executive and now author
of the new book american reboot an
idealist's guide to getting big things
done in it he takes on several problems
including restoring the republican party
and improving national leadership with
chapters like appeal to the middle not
the edges don't pander build trust and
build the workforce of tomorrow not
yesterday we know in 2022 republicans
are going to take the house that's
almost a fate accompli and we're likely
to take back the senate as well
and the reason the primary reason
driving this is because of the
incompetence on the democratic side and
so how about if we if we take advantage
of that incompetence uh put forward some
ideas that are based on our values a
talk about the future i think that puts
us in a way better position
in future elections
part of
your focus is on
stepping off the x as you put it
um sort of moving out of crisis mode all
the time and and this nonstop appeal to
sort of the far reaches of of either
party
um but is is that something that people
are ready to hear
they need to i think people are ready to
hear this this is how i won elections
nobody thought a black republican on the
texas mexico border would win in a 71
latino district and i did that three
times nobody thought i had a chance and
and the reason that we need to start
talking about the future is because i
look i want to make sure that this
century stays the american century and
we are actually we're talking about this
new cold war with russia but we're
actually in a new cold war with the
chinese government as well and they are
trying to surpass us as the world's
global superpower the russians don't
have the capability to do that the
chinese government does and and we to be
ready for this we need to be talking
uh about solutions and we need to get
beyond these kind of fear-mongering and
i believe that way more unites us as a
country than divides us and and people
are looking for inspiration and i can
give examples in heat in texas we had 3
million people vote in our primary on
march 1st out of 30 million though
that's a terrible number and the reason
is that people are not providing those
other 27 million folks with something
that people want to come out and vote
for
how do you win over people
or maybe are you not trying to win over
people who support the former president
are you concerned that a substantial
number of republicans just won't listen
to anti-trump sentiment
well it's not necessarily anti-trump you
know the things i'm talking about is
about the future and it's about
technology it's about how we can be
better dealing with russia how do we
better deal with the border crisis
that's outrageous right now it's the
worst that it's ever been so those are
the things that i talk about and look i
i took the strategy when i was in
congress i agreed when i agreed i
disagreed when i disagreed and i did
that with his predecessor democrat
president obama so it's not about any
particular individual in my opinion
the book certainly makes no no bones
about criticizing trump though and i
read an article in the atlantic called
the revenge of the normal republicans
very supportive of the appeal that
you're making in general but then i read
another article written by the former
spokesman for jon huntsman's
presidential campaign calling it wish
casting and saying that there aren't
enough so-called normal republicans to
make this work essentially
what is it that keeps you
hopeful about all of this
well first off my dad who i get to talk
a lot about in the book and you know all
we said have a pma a positive mental
attitude and what keeps me hopeful is
that running in a hotly contested
district um it flipped back and forth
between parties for for a decade i was
the first person to hold it three cycles
in a row and the thing that i learned
is that i don't care who you are where
you're from what you do you care about
putting food on your table a roof over
your head and making sure that the
people you love are healthy happy and
safe and when you talk about those
issues there's a lot of people i would
say it's 80 the country that is focused
on those things and so just because
we've been doing something the same way
for the last couple of decades doesn't
mean we have to continue uh doing it
that way and that's the whole reason
that i wrote the book and that's where i
talk about my lessons in the cia one of
those being that get off the x right the
x is where something's going down and
that's the last place you want to be
when something's going down that we need
to try something different because the
challenge is ahead of us
we're not going to be able to solve the
way we've been trying to solve problems
now
your personal and professional
background you know certainly inform
your perspective including your time as
a cia operative and as a congressman you
made a point of spending time with
constituents who vote democratic and you
made a forceful point in the book about
listening and not just campaigning
yeah look you got to show up right
i think most folks listen i'm like yeah
doesn't everybody do that it's like no
they they don't and you know one of the
things that i had to do if every
republican voted for me in my district i
would not win i had to get independents
i had to get democrats and so i had to
take conservative values to places that
had never seen a a conservative before
and so that's the battle for the hearts
and minds and what i've found is and our
ideas are better like they resonate
better you have you know when it comes
to like education there's been a 20-year
longitudinal study done in texas about
school choice and about how charter
schools eliminate the achievement gap in
all communities this is something that
we should be championing and when you
take that to a deep blue district and
talk about kids making sure that their
kids are prepared for jobs that don't
exist today and here's how you do it
people start listening when you start
talking about how to actually solve you
know challenges of the border because
folks along the border even though they
have probably identified with the
democratic party for a long time and
they see border security as a public
safety issue and they're sick and tired
of problems not being solved and so when
you go and you talk about issues that
people really care about you'll be
surprised at how people are willing to
open up their ears but you show up
listen to people and um you realize that
way more united system divides us
how much does this concept of an
american reboot or a political
intervention if you will
how much does it hinge on either party
being willing to want
to compromise you know to let their
constituents win by getting things done
instead of just focusing on which party
is winning an argument
a great question and here's my
philosophy on this
party should be driven by the people you
represent with only 3 million people
voting in a primary in texas that means
27 million people didn't
and if you only talk to the same people
over and over you get the same results
and so it's an opportunity it's hard but
the country demands this i've been lucky
to have benefited from this country i
have you know more opportunities than my
father had i want to make sure that the
next generation has more opportunities
than i've had and that's why i think
it's important to fight for some of
these ideas and have these conversations
on how do we ensure that this experiment
that has led to 247 years of improvement
in american society to where
we are i want to make sure we see that
continue for another 247 years
if republicans do take back control of
one or both chambers of congress
does it make it harder for republicans
to buy the changes you're selling
well look if we aren't careful if we
don't recognize that it's it's
democratic incompetence that has fueled
some of our gains
and don't provide a clear vision of the
future and then govern because when we
take over people are gonna expect some
changes and they're gonna expect some
things to get done and if we don't do it
then guess what democrats and joe biden
is going to blame a recalcitrant house
or a cal strength senate on the reason
for all the ills in the country and so
the likelihood that both chambers are in
republicans hands at the beginning of
2023 is quite high but you know what you
do with that power is going to matter
for later elections are you going to run
for president
look i i appreciate the folks that
you write a really good book and
everybody thinks you're going to run for
president if the opportunity for me
to serve my country again
happens then then i'll evaluate that and
i've been lucky to serve my country in a
lot of different ways my time in the cia
was awesome it was fun recruiting spies
and still in secrets on some of the most
important national security challenges
it was cool representing a district as
big as georgia in congress but right now
for me i think the contribution i can
make is talk about these ideas and talk
about our future and say that there's a
there's a different way
there's a different way to make sure
that we stay as successful as we have
been i'm going to put you down as a
maybe i think i heard basically heard
maybe
one other quick thing i want to ask you
about
and that is
the
russian war in ukraine
do you think that the current
administration should be
handling something differently and i ask
that in part because of your cia
background your cyber security
background background um you know from
the standpoint of the intelligence that
we
in part have to rely on for the
decisions we're making
look absolutely lisa i appreciate the
question and yes this administration
should be doing a lot more and we should
be thinking about this is how do we
prevent
the massacre of ukrainians and one way
to do that is to give them as much
equipment as they need and they can
absorb and this notion that oh that's
going to lead to some
escalation vladimir putin has shown the
ability to level death and destruction
what you're seeing happening in mario
paul can happen anywhere else in the
country but the best way to do to make
sure this thing ends is that make sure
to give the ukrainians all the help they
can in order to win uh this war and then
also this administration instead of
trying to restart a terrible deal with
iran
they should be going into the rest of
the western hemisphere and helping them
and getting them to be involved in these
embargoes and these sanctions against
russia when you look at the countries
that are not supporting these this
embargo against russia it's pretty stark
it's pretty shocking and so instead of
trying to work with many of our allies
to help join this to continue to put
pressure on vladimir putin and then we
should also be talking about
reconstruction like how do we help the
ukrainians rebuild how do we provide the
kind of humanitarian support all of
these have to be dealt with and this is
something the administration should be
showing leadership and i'm not seeing
enough
former texas congressman will hurd
congratulations on your book it's called
american reboot an idealist's guide to
get to getting big things done and thank
you so much for your time
thank you lisa for having me on
[Music]
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa read and review the fox
news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
one of two flamingos that escaped from a
kansas zoo 17 years ago has been spotted
off the coast of texas
officials with the coastal fisheries
division of texas parks and wildlife
told the associated press that the
african flamingo think long legs a long
neck and those pretty pink feathers was
seen on video shot on march 10th near
port lavaca northeast of corpus christi
an environmental activist shot the video
and officials were able to make out the
bird's leg band on it showing the number
492.
number 492 escaped from the sedgwick
county zoo in wichita along with another
flamingo during a storm in june of 2005.
employees hadn't yet clipped their wings
to prevent them from flying so that
helped with the getaway the other
flamingo was not seen again but it turns
out that old number 492 has had quite
the scenic journey
it's been spotted several times in
wisconsin louisiana and texas sometimes
with other wild flamingos you know what
mama always says about getting in with
the wrong crowd
zoo officials say they never planned to
recapture number 492 despite the
sightings saying there's just no easy
way to do it without disturbing the
wildlife so while the rest of the zoo
animals are wondering what it would be
like to be out loose in the world number
492 is out here living its best flamingo
life tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind president biden's
euro tour played like many a horror
movie where things go from eerily off to
a full-blown crisis in a matter of
seconds his trip was meant to reassure
europeans that when it comes to beating
back russian president vladimir putin
america is in it to win it
what happened was something else
entirely on the surface the folksy uncle
joe routine plays really well in europe
biden's statements of solidarity along
with his reassurances of u.s commitment
for ukraine and the defense of nato get
good press
most importantly for most european
leaders he never asked them for anything
more than they are already willing to do
he is the inoffensive bystander in chief
trailing behind the likable biden
however is a dark shadow
two perplexing problems pose a nagging
worry for the future of the
transatlantic community one is biden's
continued pension for face planting gas
that the white house must then explain
away this trip included at least a half
dozen from suggesting american troops
would deploy to ukraine to implying the
us would respond to a russian use of
chemical weapons with chemical weapons
which the us does not even have it does
not help that a national security team
that has proven itself sub-par backs
biden
vice president harris's european visit
for instance look like the stuff of a
saturday night live sketch the white
house would be hard-pressed to cite one
positive outcome
as if their halting response to the
ukraine crisis weren't enough the word
around washington is that biden's dream
team is only days away from announcing a
new iran deal one that's even weaker
than the last
sure to spark new tensions and conflict
in the region and bound to raise more
questions about the competence of biden
and his advisors
the second problem
is a deeper one
deeper than the cognitive abilities of
the president and his team's lack of
competence
it is that they have shown no skill
no ability to formulate and execute
strategy to safeguard the long-term
interests of the united states
more than a year after taking office
biden boasts a national gender strategy
but still no national security strategy
the lack of strategic vision
is particularly troubling right now
how is the us going to lead after this
war to ensure that putin never troubles
us again the russian president remains a
military threat
and still has energy as a weapon of
blackmail coercion profit and influence
biden
doesn't have a long-term response for
either
we need strengthened conventional and
strategic deterrence and energy
independence
biden has offered band-aids
and wishful hopes
and make no mistake
the chinese communist party has taken
note of this weakness
biden can hope putin goes away
and that renewable energy powers the
free world all he wants
but both are our magical thinking
in the end
this trip is a reminder that americans
are led by a tired man
of limited ability
backed by a team who are no better at
this now
than they were under obama
jim carafano at the heritage foundation
thanks for listening
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news listen and
download the fox news hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com